a little women la star is putting on her  dancing shoes I cannot wait a source  confirmed to et Thursday Terra Jolie has  joined season 23 of Dancing with the  Stars  the reality star may be a newcomer to  the competition but should be a tough  contender for the Mirrorball trophy ET  has an exclusive sneak peek from the  lifetime show's mid-season of a pregnant  era showing off her impressive moves in  a dance class I never had anybody go  into labor while doing belly dancing not  yet another big surprise this season max  Murkowski is making his return to the  ballroom after several seasons away  everything the weight came together and  the way I ended up back on there to the  stars as a pro this season is very  different than any other season that  I've done and and I'm looking forward to  that new sort of way of being in the  show